what about African bees uh well that's a
great one for me to tell you guys that
we for this season no baby episode 13
thousand bees in a bee period you won't
it won't come up on and I'll bring it up
on my phone real quick to show you guys
that the picture so I wore 13 thousand
bees I think you guys new baby happened
after I was on the show last I got stung
60 times in the face by bees so if you
search you're gone wrong search be beard
gone wrong quick now see what happened
to you because Africanized bees got in a
fight with European honey bees on my
face and go to images go to go to
anymore come up so there eat there you
go now that's what happened to my face
is that true yes I that's 60 times by
bees yeah look at his lip you look this
pious I look like a swollen hot dog but
we went back to Arizona and I said
incredible hold on they were Africanized
so the African bees stung the [ __ ] out
look at that yeah yeah I got my lips my
neck my around my eyes so this was I was
trying to wear a beard with about 2000
Photoshop that's your remote
that's real so for the show we just did
another bee episode I did 13 thousand
bees how heavy is your face here that's
about 11 pounds worth of bees what do
they put like a queen bee in your mouth
so I wore something called the Queen's
necklace which is a queen bee inside of
a little capsule and all of the other
worker bees that were in this hive they
just want to come to the Queen so they
basically covered me now what happened
and the one that went wrong how do you
get them off you used my be expert
scoops them off with his hand I was
stung four times filming this scene so
way less than sick girl stung still
stung four times process because the
bees were like no don't take me away
from the Queen so some of them would
sting when they're getting taken away
that's a big problem dude yeah now but
that episode is crazy awesome intense
can I tell you where you take it to the
next level dude beer B pubes makes your
dick there did you like this
[ __ ] swollen hey guys get the cameras
out no look at this [ __ ] cage dancing
did you know that they were Africanized
know so what happened with this is where
we were filming so Africanized bees are
like a big sort of thing that swept the
nation in like the early nineties with
this idea that there's killer bees
killer bees are what are called
Africanized bees right and they're only
killer bees in that people have died
from being stung by them right they're
not going on their way to necessarily
kill people but we're trying yes they
are more aggressive and when they are
from Africa indigenous to Africa
originally it it it originated there and
through people doing bee keeping there
were some tests that were being done and
it's a much longer story but yes
eventually Africanized bees had escaped
interbred with calmer European honeybees
and because there was just listening to
it it's no more more intelligent
European bees just interrupt you for a
second Jared Diamond and cons germans
and steel one of the one of the ideas
was that one of the reasons Africa did
not develop as quickly as say the
Fertile Crescent Babylon and what's now
at Rock the Middle East Europe was
because you couldn't domesticate in
sub-saharan Africa you couldn't
domesticate any of the animals and it's
a real thing you can't raise cattle you
cannot raise goats you can't raise any
other stuff when you have large cats
when you have smaller cats they will
decimate I love hearing chewiness you
can't tame an elephant you can't
domesticate an elephant you can't
domesticate the water buffalo they will
kill you you can't ride a zebra they
will bite and not let go so all of the
animals in Africa and are simply not you
can't domesticate you can domesticate
cows and oxen and horse and all those
animals that were indigenous to that
area and oh by the way edible grass is
like barley millet arimin --then and
wheat grew naturally in places like 'wow
iraq and those places so you you could
you could and and you also couldn't
really plant in an area that got rain
that often in a jungle there were just
too many issues too many insects that
would eat your
so you had to be a hunter-gatherer you
had to hunt and when you are that way
when you in small bands of people are
the only way you can survive because you
can have feed enough people mm-hmm so
you you so you couldn't organize into
law so you of course you became very
tribal and small when you have an
ability to create agriculture and and
and cereals and high energy foods that
allow you then to have a lot of people
in one area and that's when you have
government organized armies organized
technology the sharing of ideas the
sharing of information that was not the
case in in Africa and oh by the way the
diseases were I mean yellow fever and
all the it got to a point where the
slave traders do European slave traders
had to rely on other Africans to give
them their slaves they couldn't go into
the interior because they always always
got sick and died wow I love hearing
[ __ ] like interest me people ask me what
to read all the time read Guns Germs and
Steel by Jared Diamond it's it won a
Pulitzer Prize it's an amazing book Guns
Germs of steel I'm getting out
audiobooks are [ __ ] great book keep
going so the bees yeah
Africanized bees are more aggressive but
for again that's I mean it's a great
example because they're dealing with
predators like honey badgers right so
when an Africanized colony is attacked
by predator unlike European honey bees
they send out somewhere between 60 and
80 percent of their hive to attack the
attacker whoa in my instance what
happened is we were using calm docile
European honey bees to build that first
bee beard the location we were in some
Africanized bees had gotten mixed in and
in the flurry of what was happening the
second I got stung the first time my
first sting came on the lip when a bee
stings it sets off a pheromone that
tells the other bees we need to attack
something my face just sort of
inadvertently became the punching bag
for these bees getting in serious
trouble well a single bee sting can kill
a human depending how your body reacts
to venom if you go into anaphylactic
shock so to be stung as many times as I
huh about 60 times on my face alarms
emac hands legs yeah that's so much pain
mm-hmm
it wasn't terrible it was one of the
most intense pains I've ever gone
through here when your face is going
through that transformation swelling it
felt like my lips were gonna explode
they were like overly cooked hot dogs it
was crazy I was I was scared like your
heart rate starts going so fast cuz
you're like holy cow this is insanely
painful I can't stop it and there's a
lot of venom inside you take do you take
anti-venom no not for this I mean after
20 minutes when you're like okay you
haven't gone into anaphylactic shock
you're like you're gonna be okay
are you are you do you do you are you
able to build a resistance to venom the
more you get stung the more your body's
used to it or they're really obviously
well some people become more susceptible
to them so me wearing the beard the
second time we were actually worried
about is that my body built up an over
sensitivity to the venom where a single
sting could shoot me into anaphylactic
shock because you have to think when I
got stung that many times my body went
into like massive overdrive this is like
you know a Dodge Viper on nitrous like
is fascicle my body's like holy cow dude
you just got stung 60 times by bees but
you worked hard for your money
I mean this wasn't even supposed to
happen so when it went at Dan you know
we didn't go into the bee beer being
like sweet dude you're gonna get stung a
bunch the guy was working with us like
know you might get stung once or twice
so he felt really bad and when we came
back to do another bee beard free animal
plan he's like you sure you want to do
this again I'm like yeah let's go first
major right now yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]